Hello, friends. Welcome to Phoenix and
Flame.
We have an amazing guest with us today,
a fellow licensed therapist.
Tess Bregham is a licensed therapist,
certified coach, and TEDx speaker who has
spent more than
20 years helping people figure out who
they are,
what they want.
And how to build a life that feels right
to them.
Tess, welcome to Phoenix and Flame.
~
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
I mean, we could just stop right there,
right? And and talk a lot about just that.
And we will, but I wanted to add in that
you've been dubbed
the Millennial Therapist by CNBC,
and you work with organizations to help
them better understand
and support their youngest employees.
That sounds amazing.
So
Really take a moment and start wherever
you would like.
I really love to hear about my guests,
you know, what their backgrounds are.
You can start with CNBC. You can start
with schooling and how you
got interested in in,
Yeah.
you know, becoming a therapist and how
wherever you want to start,
we'll just kind of go together,
meander along the way and get all the
things covered.
Yeah. It's what's funny is when I work
with a new client,
I actually see that same thing.
When it's time, you know, you've given
them all of the the things that
you need to say and you've done all the
housekeeping stuff.
You're like, okay, well start wherever you
want to start.
You can start with exactly what you said.
I think we have very similar styles,
I get the sense of. But yeah, I I mean,
I did not I I did not think I was ever
gonna be a therapist or a coach.
Like I this was not my dream in life.
I was
someone who I loved entertainment and
movies and TV and pop culture and
all of that stuff. And I was in all the
high school plays and,
you know, I was like the theater kid.
And then I went, I was a, I got a
bachelor's of science in broadcasting and
film.
And while in school, I interned at
Columbia Pictures.
I interned with Warner Brothers.
Like I was it. Like I am have always been
a very ambitious person and likes,
you know, constantly kind of what's next,
what's next.
And so I came back to the Bay Area.
This is where I'm from, the San Francisco
Bay Area.
And I got a job right away working with
actors as a talent agent,
you know, and then it was in San
Francisco.
And then I moved to LA when I was 24.
And, you know, I pursued this was my dream
my entire life was this,
you know, and I had really centered my
identity around it.
And so when I got to LA, it was,
it was a bit of a culture shock and it
was,
it was a lot to take in, but
By I got there at 24, I left by 27 because
I had basically what I realized now,
I didn't know it at the time, but I
realized now a quarter life crisis
essentially
Interesting.
at 27. I
I sort of I just melted down. I I worked
for this woman who
was amazing and wonderful. She's still in
the business today,
still just wish me happy birthday a month
ago.
Like she is a lovely person. And I thought
to myself,
if I can't make it working with this
woman,
if I like I have a prized job that people
want.
that you know and I have the best
situation and if I can't make this work
for me if I'm unhappy then I gotta get out
of here.
And I yeah and I left and it was it was
really big at the time because like
I said my whole identity was wrapped up in
Tess in Hollywood,
right? Tess works in the business.
Tess knows these people, Tess has,
you know, does cool sh cool stuff.
And all of that, you know, she's she's
hobnobbing.
And so that was huge for me.
But it
It sort of brought me what I realized from
that experience was that when
I came home, I was, you know, exhausted
and ~ moved back in with my mom.
I had no money. And ~ but it took me a
little bit,
but not, you know, a couple of years to
kind of figure out like what did
I like the most about my job, what worked
for me,
what didn't work for me. And I really
found that the the thing that I liked
the most was helping people with their
problems.
Like I really kind of didn't care about
the jobs actors was were getting.
I was more like,
What's happening over here? And who's
saying this to like I could just deal with
people well, but I didn't really like the
business and what the business
was and what my job would be. ~ because it
didn't feel very it didn't feel very
fulfilling. but also I just I had friends
who were in the business who
are still in the business and they were
fascinated by it.
So I just like I yeah, I gotta get out.
Went to grad school and then about twelve
plus years ago,
I opened up a
Off at a therapy practice in downtown San
Francisco,
not knowing who was gonna show up.
And all of a sudden, all of these 25,
26, 27-year-old, mainly females,
started showing up. And I was like,
~ you're these millennials. I've heard so
much about.
Because I'm a Gen
Hehehe.
Xer. And I'm a Gen Xer. So I was like,
I've been hearing and you guys getting
thrashed,
trashed in the media, and no, you're lazy
entitled.
I was like, you're not at all like this.
This isn't, this doesn't match what is
being said.
and so that got me very interested in this
time of your life,
you know, from high school, college into
30,
early 30s of, you know, what is that time
meant to be?
You know, what what should sh what should
you be doing?
And our culture tells us that you should
be figuring out your career,
finding someone as a mate, buying a house,
right? Checking off boxes. and but that's
not at all what you're supposed to do.
That's not, I just don't, I don't believe
that's the purpose.
Like you can you might check off some
boxes as you go,
but it's really about it's a it's like a
10 year process of trying things
on to see what fits.
Mm-hmm.
And then,
you know, the things that fit,
you keep, the things that don't fit,
you throw away until you get to a point
where you're like,
okay, wait, this is the kind of person I
want to be with.
Okay, this is I I wanna be married or not
married.
I wanna have kids, I don't want to have
kids,
right? All of those things, all of those
decisions that you're making along the
way.
It's we put this thing in the mind where
people are like,
just race towards it. And I'm like,
you don't know if you want it yet.
Right? I mean.
That's
that is it. I mean, and what I heard you
mention before,
because I have I'm a Gen X as well,
Mm-hmm.
and I have three children and the uppers
are in the millennial age and the
Mm-hmm.
youngest is more of a Gen Z situation.
And he's in his mid twenties now.
And it's it's hard being
Mm-hmm.
in that being in the twenties and the
Yes.
the early mid thirties and like you said,
trying on different things. Meanwhile
It's like where where do I live?
How do
Mm-hmm.
I pay bills? And then there there's the
there's the the real estate issue going
on.
The it's it's hard to be able to ~ like
buy anything.
Yeah, yeah.
And so w w
the the residents, you know, where and and
all of
the the generational ~ opinions,
~
Mm-hmm.
sometimes not great opinions that are
coming down and makes it it
Hard applies pressure, it seems like.
Yeah, yeah. Well, because the people are
right right.
You what happens if parents are looking at
where they were at twenty five,
twenty-six, and then they're looking at
their kids.
And that's unfortunately, and this is what
I encourage parents not to do,
is you can't look at it through that lens.
You can't look at it in terms of,
well, at twenty-five I had a full-time job
and I,
you know, owned a home and I did this and
I did that.
I'm like, okay. Like the world the world
is is different.
Great.
Very, very, very, very different.
I mean, in some ways, right? My parents
are like silent generation baby boomer
cuspers, you know, and that that was a lot
of the parents like baby,
like a lot of the parents of the Gen Xers.
And that's the same thing. I think I have
more in common with my parents than
I think I do with my son, who is 18 and a
Gen Z er.
Do you know what I mean? Because of
technology,
Mm-hmm.
because of things. Like my high school
experience.
matched much more of my parents' high
school experience than my son's high
school
experience. And technology is moving and
it's moving us rapidly.
It's we're going, going, going.
And so things are changing really fast and
we're having to adapt really fast.
And so I think, you know, everyone's
always cr criticized youth.
That's just how it's always been.
I just say that millennials unfortunately
were at an a at a time where everyone
had a platform to criticize them.
You know, that was the problem.
But what happened was this narratives
start to develop in our culture around
these
youngsters that are that are lazy and in
title and they're they're doing this
and they're doing that. And it's like,
no, no. They're just being kids.
They're being kids reacting to what is
where our world is today.
That's it.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, gosh, so many, whoo, so many
thoughts are going through my head
as you're talking. ~ because I'm also
processing who's listening and who's
watching
Mm.
and where they are and what they're
experiencing.
So let me just pull one thought out.
~ I feel like I'm in Harry Potter with the
pensive,
pulling one thought that out of my brain.
~ so let's talk about I'm really
interested in your thoughts
on on the one hand.
technology, you see, particularly the the
Gen Z platform,
s really adept, very good at learning new
things,
which sometimes for for Gen X I can
personally attest.
I feel like every time I turn the effing
corner,
Yes.
right, tests, there's something the
something's been changed.
Mm-hmm.
I have to
learn something new. It's like I just
freaking learned that last week.
Yeah.
Why can't I just do that for a while?
Right? Why do
Mm.
I have to learn this new thing again?
And so there's frustration that I know
what that feels like,
but the younger generation seemed like
they're so flowy with
Mm-hmm.
that and so much better at that.
But here's the thing that I want to get
your opinion on.
What do you see as the the yin and yang,
the flow between on the one hand?
being very good at technology and and and
bringing that to the workplace,
you know, working smarter,
Mm-hmm.
not harder, this kind of thing,
learning quickly, being very flexible
cognitively.
And then also sometimes the underbelly of
that
is lack of interpersonal skills because of
the the tendency to be looking
at a screen, the, the, the, the feeling
very comfortable with communication
through
technology instead of face to face and
sometimes that rears its ugly head
in relationships at at personal and at
work.
I'm really curious about your your
experience and your take on that.
Yeah, I and so the thing is is that yeah,
Gen Z and young people, they do.
They are, you know, it they adapt.
It's the best time to learn things.
And I think we have to also recognize
that,
especially with Gen Z, they were they've
had these phones since birth.
You know, the this is sort of their way of
life.
This is how they
see things and see the world. And that was
what was different about millennials.
The millennials kind of entered into it,
sort of like, this is new and what is this
going to be?
And trying some things out and all of
that.
I always say Gen Zers are very observant.
They watch. They've been watching and
watching.
They've been watching their parents.
They've been watching this. And so they've
entered adulthood
in a different headspace, into this place
of
Okay, I've been watching all this stuff
and I'm not gonna believe that.
Mm-mm, I'm not gonna believe that.
And and really coming at it from this
place of ~ I think what I believe is
a hell of a lot more emotional
intelligence than any young group has had.
And I think this group very much does a
much better job in general with being
mindful of people's feelings, you know,
all of those things, which I think is
great.
The the flip side of it is, yeah.
The problem is is that by the time the
average Gen Zer hits like 18,
they have more, they they're gonna have
more relationships with people
online than they are in real life.
I don't have the stat right in front of
me,
but you know, it's been it's been studied
that this generation,
yeah, does not interact or have to
interact the same way that we had to
interact.
And ~
And the thing is, is that so those are the
tools.
And that's what I always tell companies,
like these are the things that you need to
work on.
That stop stop worrying so much about,
you know, this this Gen Z are is doing
this or that,
or, you know, are they really doing work?
I said, why don't you really focus on your
training program and really focus
on how you bring them in? Because they do,
they're young, they need help in the
workforce.
And we take this attitude like they don't
know the right things,
or they don't, you know, it's like,
no, they are responding.
They are responding to everything.
Again, this is just my two cents take on
this,
but it's what I see is a lot of Gen Xers,
we are the ones raising Gen Z.
And people really didn't, you know,
I had great parents, I love my parents,
great parents, good people, raised well,
have all the advantages in the world.
But my feelings really weren't taken into
consideration all that much.
Like how I felt about things,
Yeah.
like what I wanted, what I did,
and you know, I had some.
You know, parents divorce very quickly,
you know, father remarries. Like I had
some stuff that happened where
it was very much like my feelings were
dismissed often by the world.
My parents tried, but like they were going
through their own stuff,
but by the world, you know, and it was
this attitude of you suck it up
and you move forward. And I really feel
like we were like,
we don't want to do this to our kids.
We don't want to do this to them.
And so we may have overcorrected a little
bit and maybe sort of,
you know, really went the opposite
direction,
but that
coupled with technology and the pandemic
sort of created this place that we're
in right now. so yeah,
it does look like parents have really
dropped the ball in term in terms
of social skills, but parents are really
trying,
you know, they don't want, you know,
they were bullied. So they're like,
if I can prevent bullying, I'm gonna,
you know, if I'm gonna sit there,
if I'm gonna, if my kids being bullied at
the school,
I'm not gonna tell them to suck it up.
I'm gonna move them to another school
where they can thrive.
And ~ you know, you see a lot of those
those things.
And I went through it with my son as well.
My son is highly, highly anxious and has
depression and all these things.
We had we homeschooled him, like we had a
whole other thing.
And people might say like we accommodated
him and did all these things,
but I I I'm sorry, right?
When your kid says, I can't go to school,
right? As a parent, you're you're trying
to parent that kid and help them
and figure out things. And I think that
that's what's
I think people are starting to see
parenting as much more of a not a blanket
thing,
but as an individual thing, like the kid
that's right in front of you.
You know, how do you parent them?
~ so I I I will say that I'm not saying
that
the younger generations don't have a part
in this and they don't have
a responsibility, but they're still young,
they're still the kids, they their brains
haven't completely fully formed.
And so it's on us to.
Right. To be the ones to say, okay,
this is what they need now. Right.
Instead of forcing the same we keep we
keep shoving the same things down their
throats, like of of what how we were
trained or how things were when
we were first in the workforce or how our
bosses treated us.
It's like, no, stop, stop. That's not
gonna help you.
That exactly. That's not
that's interesting but largely irrelevant,
right? And so
Yes.
so as you're talking, I several things
came to my mind.
So the first thing I wanted to get your
take on,
because I heard you mention something
about this,
is I've I've seen my youngest son do this
quite a bit,
how they observe, Gen Z in particular will
Mm-hmm.
observe
their older siblings, we'll observe
Yes.
adults, we'll observe other people,
coworkers, friends, older friends,
and say, look, I don't, I don't want to go
down that path.
Mm-hmm.
I I saw what you did and I saw what
happened.
And
Mm-hmm.
I don't want that, you know, and how do
you feel about how that plays
out interpersonally for them and also at
work when they have this ability
to call a spade a spade?
Mm-hmm.
And sometimes and and and it's it's it's
true.
Right. But sometimes people don't receive
it very well.
It's like how how to I'm just kind of
wondering what your experiences have been
in the conversations that you've had when
you have a Gen Z who's they're they're
very good truth tellers. And but
Mm-hmm. They are, yes.
but sometimes people the recipients of
that aren't receiving that very well.
What has been your experience with that in
in the stories that you've heard?
Yeah, I mean, that certainly has happened.
And it's funny because when I talk to
groups,
sometimes the older generation,
like the Gen Xers, will be like,
Are you telling the Gen Zers that they
also need to work on themselves
and do all this stuff, right? Like it's
almost this weird thing of like,
you're telling them too, right?
I'm like, Yes, of course. Of course I'm
Ha ha
telling them, you know, these things.
~ but yeah, I think that that
the truth telling and and and I think
that.
I'm always fascinated by people that get
really triggered by these truth tellers.
Right. So,
Right.
because I think it's maybe saying
something a bit more about you.
Now, the I understand that that ~ that
feeling of when the young person comes
in and starts like, well, we should be
doing this and this should be
our mission and all that. And you're kind
of like,
give me a break. How old are you?
You know, like, how dare you?
Talk, but I often say that like if you can
just their kids,
they don't know yet, you know,
that's what you want to work with them on
and the delivery,
all of that. But but maybe they do have
some ideas,
maybe they do have something to say.
I had this very interesting experience
where I recorded I was recording this
other
podcast with two other people,
both on the east coast and I'm on the west
coast.
And ~ there was the host, and he was he
was coming in and I was talking
to the other woman that was on.
We were
On this conversation. And she's a Gen Z
expert.
And but and she's also Gen Z. She's about
27,
28. And we had met before. She's been on
my show and all that.
And so I was saying, she was like,
how you doing? I'm yeah, I'm just tired.
It's 9 a.m. here on a Monday morning.
And she's Well, why are you recording
this?
I'm like, What do you mean? And she said,
Why did you say yes to this? And I said,
Well, because the two of you were on the
East Coast and it seemed like
the time that worked for you two.
And I just kind of felt like I could
handle it.
And she said, Well, and she's Well,
But you could have pushed back.
We would have picked another day.
You could have said that, you know,
you're not a morning person or you this
wouldn't have worked for you.
And so in that moment, here's the thing.
I have two directions I can go in.
I can either
Ha ha.
be like, how dare you, kid? I'm twice your
age.
Tell me how to live my life and what I
should be doing and how I should be doing
it.
And ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba.
Or I can take a huge step back and go,
huh. Did did is she right? You know,
yeah, she's right.
I could have pushed back. Like I didn't.
I wanted to be accommodating. I wanted to
accommodate.
So then the the thing is, is that it's not
like she's saying to me,
You're accommodating is bad. It's just
more of it was this moment of reflection
of,
~ wait a second, there is a different way.
There can be another way. And I think
that's a big one.
I I tell my Gen X clients all the time:
like, you have got to start listening to
these Gen Zers because they understand.
Because they have been dealing with
technology and the phones and the chaos
of the world since the beginning,
they actually understand a bit more about
how to work within themselves
and regulate their systems and figure out
what they need a bit more than we do
Mm-hmm.
in a lot of ways.
So that's an excellent example.
And I love the way
Mm-hmm.
you presented that and and your point of
view.
And and I've got because I'm as you're
talking,
I'm hearing all these voices in my head.
no people, I don't have a dissociative
identity
Mm-hmm.
disorder. But so okay,
because I'm thinking as you're talking,
because I've been involved in all these
conversations with
different generations of people with
Mm-hmm.
different personality styles, right?
Type A, type B, et cetera, on and on,
Ennegram types. So I really would like for
you to talk a little bit more about
the accommodating thing. Because
Mm-hmm.
on the one hand, like the example that you
gave,
you know, she was saying, look,
you know, you know that nine o'clock you
were going to be tired.
You know, you could
Mm-hmm.
have you could have pushed back a little
bit and kind of stood up
for yourself and say, can we, can we
possibly and they would have been willing
to change so that you would have been more
awake.
Which that's a very good point,
right? And another point that sits right
alongside that is sometimes at work
we have to do things and also in our
personal lives to be brutally honest,
we have to do things that are
uncomfortable.
And if we expect the entire world to just
accommodate
us all the time so that we're comfortable,
then that's not going to work out very
well.
Mm-hmm.
And I
think I think sometimes you have the the
Gen X.
Sometimes
Mm-hmm.
they're they go too far on the side,
like just suck it up and shut up and move
on,
Yep. Yep.
you know, just
put some dirt on it, right? Move along.
All right, that's they go too far that
way.
Sometimes there's some Gen Z that will go
too far the other direction where they
expect to be accommodated. Like I'm not
showing up,
I'm supposed to be at work at 8 30 in the
morning,
but you know, I'm just that's not that
doesn't work for me.
I'm just tired. I I'm not I'm not awake.
Can can I not come rolling in at 10
o'clock?
That works better for me.
and if it does, because there's some
places that are very flexible
Yeah.
and they're like, hey, if you want to come
in at 10 and you wanna work your eight
hours, it starts at 10 a.m. and you can
get your work done,
awesome, thumbs up, right? But there's
some places that are not that
accommodating.
They shut down at four or five o'clock and
you know,
that doesn't work so well. So I would
really like to hear your thoughts
and your experiences and maybe some
conversations you've been in about
the whole concept of accommodation,
looking at it from both both angles.
Yeah,
yeah. And what's interesting, and you know
this as a therapist,
one of the big issues that we had with my
son when we were working on
his anxiety is the therapist told that my
husband and I,
you're accommodating him. So, right,
accommodating is not right with an when it
comes to anxiety.
If you keep accommodating it, yeah,
you're absolutely right. You you teach
someone that they aren't strong enough
to do things, that they can't handle
things,
or you teach them that discomfort,
any discomfort's gonna is bad.
And ~
Any of those, you know, and so I I'm with
you that that we don't need
to accommodate every single thing for
them.
I think that there is a way that we can
better,
like you said, create because of
technology and because we have that
ability
now to create situations where we can
create working conditions that
are better for the person and the
personality,
very much so.
But I'm also very much a believer.
I had this manager once who was managing,
this was shortly after the pandemic,
like it was like 2021. And so people are
coming back to work.
And this kid was hired during the
pandemic.
~ so he was at home. And so this is a big,
big corporation. And so this guy's a
manager,
and he's having to tell this new this
hire,
like, hey, everyone's back to work on
Tuesdays and Thursdays,
starting, you know, May 1st or whatever.
And so he kept getting pushback from this
kid,
like.
kid was in Brooklyn and he didn't want to
travel to he didn't want to travel
to the city and you know it was like going
back and forth.
And this manager did try to like
investigate a few things like could you
do the and and basically the company was
like no he was hired to be
you know in person. He's coming in.
And so this manager was asking me and I
just finally said to him I said
you need to tell him I will see you at 9
a.m on Tuesday morning.
Like stop listening to his complaint.
Stop you he what was happening with him is
he
He was being, he was being overly nice,
overly accommodating. And I
Mm-hmm.
was like, you've you've gone above and
beyond for this person.
So you just need to say, I'll see you 9
a.m.
Tuesday. And if and if that's not gonna
work for you,
then I'm assuming that's your rec
resignation.
You know, and sometimes
Mm.
and he did show up at Tuesday,
I will tell you that much the kid did.
And that's the thing. Sometimes you just
have to be like,
just you just have to be there,
you know, that's it. And
And so I think that and what I try to
teach my son is the difference between
good
uncomfortable and bad uncomfortable,
right? You know, and that's the thing.
There's that, you know, the the me being
up at 9 a.m.
or having to do this podcast, like,
yeah, she's right. Because it's not like
I'm pushing myself.
I've done podcasts. I don't need to,
Ha ha
you know, this
is not an exercise that I need to,
you know, be up and do. So she's right.
Like I really could have, you know,
if I want if I if I wanted to,
if I had done that.
~ but there's other times where yeah,
that you need to feel that discomfort.
That discomfort is important. And ~ that
is,
I mean, everything that you, everything
that people want,
I know that's an old cliche statement,
but like everything that you want is on
the other side of discomfort.
It really is. And and so yeah,
it's like what I say to people all the
time is you've just got to recognize that
a big part, especially when you're young,
is gonna be a lot of discomfort.
A lot of discomfort. And that's okay.
A lot of times what I find, especially
with young people,
is they just need someone to validate it.
They just need someone to say,
you know, yes, I hear you. You're confused
about your career.
You don't feel comfortable. You don't know
where you're going here.
Like all of those, all of those things are
real and true.
And that's okay. And that's normal.
That's where you need to be. Great.
Got it. Yeah.
And I
think that that alone is incre is
incredibly helpful for people just
to know because again, we have to.
We have to remember how young people,
and I was saying this with millennials,
how young people take in other young
people,
right? When when I was in my twenties,
we didn't have any of this. But so maybe
you watch a TV show or you might
see a magazine or you might see someone
your own age that's like
a millionaire or killing it or a TV star
or whatever it is.
But but for the most part,
My day-to-day life was with my friends and
I,
and we were all lost and broke and didn't
know what the hell we were doing
and all this kind of stuff.
Ha ~
So, but imagine then if you now have this
handheld device that shows
you people's lives that look amazing.
And even if you intellectually know that
that this has been created,
even though you know your friend Molly
hates her job,
and but she but she's on a two-week trip
to Bali and and you're jealous,
and so
That's the problem. The problem is that
they have this,
this ex example of this is who you should
be.
This is what, this is what success looks
like.
Your life sucks because it's not this.
Yes.
And ~ and so, and there's and because
they're spending less time with other
people
their own age in person, they're not able
to have those moments of like,
well, I'm looking around and everyone
seems to be lost here.
So it's
Ha ha
not just me.
And so that's the other thing too is I
found when the millennials first started
showing up in my office, like how many of
them were like the comparison
and the comparisonitis and the like I'm
watching this person and this person's
doing
this. And it's like okay,
okay. Do you want to do that? Is that what
you want to do?
Because I went through this too with
someone,
~ this younger woman who ~ we were
chatting and she was traveling constantly
and
She's a friend of mine and ~ she's a coach
and she was traveling everywhere.
And I was telling her, I'm like,
my God, I'm I get so jealous sometimes.
I see you, like you're in London and then
you're here in Thailand and blah,
blah, blah. And then she wrote me back and
she said,
honestly, I sometimes see you.
You're married, you have a home,
you have a kid, you have this life that
you've built.
And it's that recognition of, yeah,
you know, as much as I want to maybe be
someone who's a jet setter,
~ that's not what I picked. And it's not,
it's not what I want.
You know, and that's the other part of it
too,
is we see things that we think I should
want that,
or I or that looks very appealing.
And so then that becomes we start to
question things.
And it's like, no, I I you know,
again, I had that conversation with her
maybe 10 plus years ago.
And I'm at I'm in my 50s now and I love
being in my 50s.
It's like the best. I just love it.
It's like the greatest decade.
And so my feelings about things are very,
very different. I don't have that same
level of angst,
but that I used to, but
but it was very eye-opening of yeah,
you know, you can't have it all.
You you you you can have it all,
but you just can't have it at the same
time.
And that, yeah, when you make certain
choices in your life,
it does mean that thing other things
aren't gonna happen.
But that's what our lives are made up of.
And at the end of the day, I don't wanna
be in I like being at home with
my kid and my dogs and doing my thing and
having coffee.
Like I don't wanna be in London.
I don't want I would love to travel more.
I need to do that, but I I don't I don't
need to be living out
of a suitcase somewhere. And so
Mm-hmm.
that's what it really comes down to are
the choices that we make.
And and and feeling good about those
choices.
That's why you need to experiment.
That's why I'm saying you have to try
things on to see
Mm-hmm.
if, okay, does this fit? Does this feel
good?
Yeah. And and experiencing things along
the way.
I know our our time's about up,
but I
Mm-hmm.
I had an experience that I wanted to get
your take on real quick before we wrap up.
And if we look at it from the angle of
communication and also expectations,
~ because me being the Queen of
Boundaries,
I find myself in some some interesting ~
interactions and interesting
conversations.
Mm-hmm.
And I had one where there was a corporate
~ individual and he
He had kind of a bad taste in his mouth
about boundaries
Mm-hmm.
because there was a a young person who had
come to work for him.
And she basically she was misusing the
term.
Yeah.
And she was basically said, you know,
I'm gonna leave right at a certain time.
I'm gonna leave right at four o'clock.
I'm not
Mm-hmm.
taking any calls after that. That's my
boundary.
I'm leaving at four. I don't care how many
calls are coming in.
I'm walking out the door. That's my
boundary.
Mm-hmm.
And so he had this really nasty taste in
his mouth.
And it got me wondering what was explained
to her when she was hired?
Yeah.
You know, how did you describe the job?
You know, did you say that sometimes
you're going to have to stay after and
take,
you know, if it's a particularly busy day,
you might have to stay after, you know,
15 minutes, 30 minutes if to accommodate
the phone calls?
Or did you tell her that she was she came
in at eight o'clock and she
was going to leave at four o'clock?
Mm-hmm.
~
every single day, at which point she's
just taking you at your word.
Yeah.
so I'm just kind of wondering,
'cause you he was an older gentleman,
Yes.
and he just he was, to be honest,
he was kind of used to sort of kind of
pushing people to do whatever
and and not really respecting boundaries,
and he was he didn't really understand how
boundaries fit into the workplace.
And so this experience with this one
woman,
this younger, pretty much a Gen Z woman,
~ just really left him with a hugely bad
taste in his mouth.
And
Yeah.
I w I was trying to get him to understand
that's not she was she was using
the word boundaries, but it was really
maybe an avoidance tactic.
I don't know, but it kinda depends on the
communication.
So
Mm-hmm. yeah.
have you run into any situations like that
from stories that you've heard from your
yes.
people?
yeah, yeah. That's that this one's more
common than people think,
which is you get someone who, you know,
has been working for the last 40 years and
they've interviewed a million people
and this is their spiel and they say it.
And exactly. I mean, I'd be very curious
to learn from him.
What did you say in the interview?
What did you say? Did
Yeah, that's what I mm hmm.
you say, did you say this job is from
eight to four?
~ or did you say that it's from eight to
five,
but the phones we shut the phones off at
four,
but then this, I mean, what did you say?
And yeah, they're gonna she doesn't have
another experience.
The thing is, is that yeah, you know,
that when I started work, I really went
into it and I worked in Hollywood.
I just want to say, like, abuse,
it the the people in L there was abuse.
A man looked down my shirt and made a
comment about my breasts one day.
Like, and who was I gonna go to?
They weren't gonna protect me.
They weren't gonna do anything for me.
They'd tell me to shut up because it was
an actor,
whatever. And so here we are entering the
workforce.
And so we somehow think that that's,
you know, and so we're gonna keep
perpetuating this idea of,
you know, yeah, I'm gonna tell you ki I'm
gonna tell you what the job is,
but I'm gonna have all these other
expectations of you that I'm that
are gonna be silent. I'm gonna leave you
at this point where you never know when
to leave. Cause that was a big one too,
when
Know you weren't supposed to leave before
your boss left.
And so bosses would stay till like nine,
10 o'clock at night, and it was just
really crazy and you didn't know,
Crazy.
but
you felt like, my God, my job depended on,
or I'm I'm not a team player if I don't do
those things.
Mm-hmm.
So that's the thing. And for someone like
him,
I would say, yeah, you have to go back and
clarify what you mean and then say,
you know, is this still are you still
interested?
You know, this is what it is.
And then the other thing that I tell
people is when you run into these kinds
of situations where you've got someone who
maybe they are coming in
a little bit later or maybe you're worried
about the way they're
the or they're wearing sweatpants or
whatever it is.
I always say instead of sitting them down
and saying like you're doing this,
like scolding them, just saying,
you know, hey, let's talk about your you
know,
let's talk about work, let's talk about
how you're doing,
and let's talk about how do you,
how do you want to be perceived?
How do you want to be seen? How do you
want to show up?
At work? Do you want to be seen as someone
like this,
or do you want to be seen as someone like
you know?
And what will happen is a lot of times
they'll be Well,
I want to be seen, I want to be taken
seriously.
And so so, like, how do you think?
So, how would you dress? You know,
what do you think people think that is?
And listen, they might say, No,
I my sweatpants don't matter. Okay.
So if you and if you don't have a
sweatpant policy,
again, yeah.
That's it. They're gonna challenge it.
They're gonna say, look,
it what's the big deal? I can still get my
job done just fine
Mm-hmm.
in my sweatpants. So I that's the part
about the one of the many parts about
the whole Gen Z generational kind of
pushes,
they challenge.
Yeah.
You know, they're like, Yeah, I'm in
sweatpants,
but I'm it doesn't impede my ability to do
my job.
And so
Mm-hmm.
it it forces you to kind of rethink.
All these expectations that we had that we
just took for granted.
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
We just we just
kind of swallowed it and went on because
nobody ever really challenged
the status quo. Well, they challenge.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. yeah. And it's good for them to
challenge.
They they
need to challenge because here's the
thing.
When we started working, I don't know how
old you are,
but like when we started working,
but even though like but when I left the
office,
I was done. I was done. So work life and
home life was very set.
I did not have to worry about boundaries.
Boundaries were created for me.
You know, I couldn't work on the weekends
because I didn't have a computer
at my house, you know, like.
All of those things. So you had these set
boundaries.
So when millennials came into the
workforce,
what happened was that they had no
knowledge of anything.
And then we had these phones that we then,
you know, abused them with essentially.
A lot of ~ managers and bosses,
I'm sorry, you were texting your people on
a Saturday and Sunday.
And I had a lot of conversations with
clients who would tell me,
like, even though I set the boundary and I
didn't text them back,
they're they're anxious all weekend long
about Monday morning,
like what's
Yeah.
gonna happen.
And and these older managers have this
attitude of,
well, why are they stressed out?
I I told them it's not a big deal.
I'm like, because they're 24 and this is
their first job.
And and they want to impress you.
And this makes them anxious. They're not
you.
And and that's the biggest thing is that
we have to stop thinking about,
like when we think about younger people,
we have to stop thinking about who you
were at that age,
but really stop and plop yourself into.
What is it like to be a 26 year old,
27 year old today? And so when I give
these talks,
I'll have people like, I want you to think
about your college graduation
and I want you to think about that day and
what it meant to you.
And now I want you to think about it in
your high school bedroom.
I want you to think about like a a car,
someone handing you a diploma outside of a
car.
Like then which is very much what happened
to all of these kids that graduated
during the pandemic. And
Yeah.
so we take this attitude like,
you know, we know them or we that we know
what they're gonna.
It's like, no.
We don't. So so stop.
Yeah.
Think about where we are today and and and
information and how much information
is out there and what they're taking in
and then and then start working with them.
This is wonderful. I just love the the
point of view that you're presenting,
the perception, ~ the experience that
you've had.
Now I know that people are listening and
thinking,
my gosh, Tess is awesome. I love her her
her point of view.
How where do you want them to go to to
connect with you,
to learn more about you, to find out the
resources that you have?
Yeah, the best thing to do is just go to
my website,
testbrigham.com. I have a complimentary
free workbook called the
Gen Z Retention Playbook, which talks a
lot about the things that I've been
talking
about here. So go to my website and you
can download it.
And I have other resources. I've done a
lot of video series that are
on there about ~ you know, about various
things that come up,
like how to give Gen Z feedback,
how to do this, how to do that.
And then I have a
Two podcasts, actually. You, if you're
interested,
if you enjoyed this conversation,
you can check out my podcast, The Gen Mess
with Tess.
And then I have another podcast that I've
been doing with my sister called Psych
Legal Pop. She's an attorney. I'm a
therapist.
So we talk about popular culture.
We talk a lot about Sister the show Sister
Wives,
if people are interested. A lot of the
documentaries and sister wives.
So if you're a fan, check us out.
Psych Legal Pop.
I love this. Tess,
I thank you so much for willing to,
you know, coming on the Phoenix and Flame
podcast and sharing your time,
your energy and your expertise with myself
and all my listeners.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you for having me.
guys, I know you have heard multiple
things in this podcast that you're
thinking,
I have a friend, I have a coworker,
I have a relative that absolutely needs to
hear what Tess Brigham has to say.
So take this podcast episode, copy and
paste it,
send it in text, send it email email,
put it on your favorite social media site
so we can grow our Phoenix
and Flame community and let people know
you are not alone.
I hope your day has been great.
I hope the rest of it is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.